aiguisez l'oeil et châteaux et l'esprit
c'est ce qu'ont voulu marcel bénabou et
paul fournel les créateurs du jardin des
voyages les ignames toujours bailly il y
à une coquille dans notre jardin et et
nous remercions bernard notre jardinier
pour l'avoir fait
nous sommes aux hommes du texte donc on
a pensé que le nôtre jardin devait être
un jardin de texte on pensait faire
remplacer chaque lettre par une fleur
mais c'était évidemment trop difficile
et trop complexe à lire donc on a
remplacé les voyelles de notre texte par
des fleurs chaque voyelle correspond à
une couleur et donc on peut lire le
poème
donc c'est un poème qui a été écrit pour
le jardin chaumont on a choisi de faire
un onze un espace a choisi de faire un
rose 1 parce que là car la plus proche
du lieu est celle de 11
voilà est donc on a fait un problème de
11 verges avec consigne par tard vers
est alors l'idée évidemment était
d'inviter les visiteurs du château à
venir lire le poème tranquillement
depuis le petit balcon de prendre le
temps et on s'aperçoit qu'il ne fonde
long thier à haute voix et partage c'est
un bon un très bon moment
en quittant le jardin des voix niel on
entre dans l'univers imaginaire
et fantastique d'harry potter on vient
de traverser la forêt interdite où les
pensées se bousculent on va être à terme
enfermés dans des lianes qui vont venir
assombrir l'espace et plus on avance
dans notre promenade dans ce jardin plus
effectivement nos pensées vont s'apaiser
surtout quand on va arriver au prochain
ex pas ce qui est le l'espace de la
pensine ou là effectivement on est amené
à déposer nos pensées dans la pensine
d'harry potter
on avait vraiment voulu dans ce lieu
sollicité tous les sens que ce soit la
vue l'odorat l'ouïe est également le
toucher puisqu'on a beaucoup de plantes
qui sont des plantes aromatiques on est
allé puiser dans les grimoires on
navigue vraiment le promeneur a touché
ces végétaux lamente la camomille l'art
tennis
l'idée c'est de se laisser bercer
s'apaiser en faisant en sollicitant tous
les sens après cette escapade à notre
voyage de nouvelles sensations dans la
chaleur moite ou presque de l'amazone
ici nous avons reconstitué depuis 96 un
petit peu là masoni pour changer un
petit peu l'esprit des jardins qui sont
un petit peu comme un plein soleil les
25 parcelles d'arriver dans un endroit
hui de l amazonie pour descendre ce
vallon des brumes il ya 4500 marche
ici nous sommes déjà à vingt mètres de
profondeur on encore 8 mais le wallon a
été créé vraiment artificiellement donc
un grand bassin en rock des pompes et
pillé la brumisation l'eau est recyclée
remonte à la pompe et les jardins de la
pensée c'est le nom de cette 27e édition
du festival international de chaumont
sur loire
c'est jusqu'au 4/9